"Elena está cultivando plantas de tomate y
estudiando sus alturas, con esto obtuvo los
datos siguientes". La planta del tomate tipo Bola
tiene una altura de 3 pies 1/4, la planta del tipo
Roma 2 pies 7/8 y del tipo Cereza 3 pies 1/2, y
nos preguntan ¿cuál es la diferencia entre las
alturas de la planta del tomate Bola y la planta
del tomate Roma? Es decir, entre este tomate
y el tomate Roma. Nos piden que encontremos la
diferencia entre estas dos alturas. Así que para
el propósito de este video la altura de la planta
del tomate tipo Cereza es innecesaria, entonces
queremos encontrar la diferencia entre estas
dos alturas, por lo tanto, restaremos la altura
más pequeña a la más grande, es decir, queremos
evaluar 3 y 1/4 - 2 y 78. Ahora, la primera cosa
que nos gustaría hacer es convertir estos números
mixtos en fracciones impropias, entonces 3 enteros
y 1/4 es lo mismo que 3 + 1/4, que es lo mismo que
12/4 + 1/4, esto es lo mismo que 3 enteros y 1/4,
y a esto vamos a restarle 2 enteros y 7/8, 2 y 7/8
es lo mismo que 2 + 7/8, 2 es lo mismo que 16/8, y
a esto le sumamos 7/8. Básicamente esto es lo que
queremos encontrar. Ahora, ¿cuánto es 12/4 + 1/4?
Bueno, eso es lo mismo que 13/4, 13 / 4. Ahora,
¿cuánto es 16/8 + 7/8? Esto es lo mismo que 23/8,
menos 23/8. Ahora estamos restando una fracción
de otra, pero tenemos denominadores diferentes,
por lo tanto, no podremos realizar esta resta
hasta que tengamos el mismo denominador. Así
que ¿cuál es el mínimo común múltiplo entre
estos dos denominadores 4 y 8? Es decir,
¿cuál es el número más pequeño que es divisible
entre ambos, 4 y 8? Bueno, 8 es divisible entre 8
y 8 también es divisible entre 4, por lo tanto,
sí podemos reescribir 13/4 utilizando 8 como
denominador en términos de octavos, ya estaremos
listos. Así que intentémoslo, escribamos ambas
fracciones utilizando 8 como denominador. La
segunda fracción ya lo tiene, veamos: 13/4,
podemos observar que para pasar del 4 al 8 tuvimos
que multiplicar el denominador por 2, entonces,
para no cambiar el valor de la fracción, tenemos
que multiplicar el numerador por el mismo valor,
tenemos que multiplicar también por 2, tenemos
entonces 26/8 y a 26/8 le quitaremos 23/8,
y esto será igual a, tenemos a 8 como
denominador y como numerador tenemos 26 - 23,
que es igual a -merecemos nuestro
redoble de tambores- 26 - 23 es 3,
entonces 3/8. Por lo tanto ¿cuál es la diferencia
entre las alturas de la planta del tomate Bola
y la planta del tomate Roma? 3/8 y todo lo
hemos trabajado en pies, entonces 3/8 de pie.